There’s no shortage of aliens in sci-fi.
Fantastical beings from distant worlds have
been a staple of the genre since its conception.
Yet while entertaining, not all pop-culture
aliens are the most scientifically rigorous.
But The Yaetuan Sagas, a vast new speculative
evolution project from talented artist Christian
Cline, explores its titular species with breathtaking
detail.
With over two hundred pages dedicated to the
Yaetuan’s epic journey from microbes to
the stars, the book might be the densest exploration
of a single alien species ever written.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
attempt to fathom the sheer complexity of
the Yaetuans with a little help from the author
himself.
And like my videos on Cline’s other series,
The Teeming Universe, you can purchase the
book using the links below…
Our story begins around three billion years
ago, with a planet called Yaetu.
Slightly larger than earth, it is a world
perfect for the emergence of life.
On the planet’s surface, the first single
celled organisms are just beginning to develop
around hydrothermal vents deep in the heart
of the ocean.
For the next several billion years, life will
wax and wane — growing and shrinking in
accordance with mass extinctions as time spirals
onwards through different eras.
Compared to Earth’s history, life takes
its time getting onto land.
But eventually, surface-dwelling species emerge,
breathing in the crisp air.
And now, a new chapter in the story of life
can begin.
Eight million years ago, a hum fills the hazy
morning air as thousands of flying organisms
take off from a dense forest canopy.
This ancient rainforest is as large as the
continental United States, and within its
impenetrable branches a vast multitude of
species thrive — including one with a destiny
in the stars.
In the understory of the forest, the early
Protoyaetuans cling to the side of great fungal
shells with their six clawed limbs.
These tree-dwelling social omnivores are just
one of many related species, at the time content
to hold a minor niche within a larger ecosystem.
The Yaetuan Forest biosphere overflows with
abundance.
Plants, fungi, and strange composite organisms
called ‘plungi’ keep the ecosystem in
stable harmony.
But this idyllic environment will soon change
forever...
Over the next several million years, tectonic
collisions send volcanic activity into overdrive,
the resultant rapid warming transforming the
rainforest into a sparse desert.
Tens of thousands of species, the Protoyaetuans
included, are left without a home.
Yet this will not be the end of the Protoyaetuans,
but the beginning.
Forced to adapt, the species evolves to live
on the ground and take shelter in caves — becoming
more resourceful and more intelligent.
Eventually, the Protoyaetuans evolve into
true Yaetuans — the central species of the
saga.
The fundamental Yaetuan body plan is something
Cline spent extra time developing, and is
based on real science: “What I had in mind
for Yaetuans was ‘What is a good example
of traits which astrobiologists attribute
to an intelligent species?
Like, they would have a head with a large
brain.
They would have hands to manipulate stuff.”
All aspects of Yaetuan anatomy — from their
skeleton, to their internal organs, to their
nervous system, are mapped with an astonishing
amount of detail.
Their skulls are hefty to accommodate an expanded
cranium, and their beaks are actually derived
from their two front teeth — a structure
which acts as a powerful natural weapon.
Eight-hundred-and-fifty thousand years ago,
pre-historic Yaetuan hunters, the Andago people,
survey the horizon from a high vantage point
overlooking a mighty lake.
An early nomadic society, the Andago traverse
vast distances in search of game, and have
learned to wear face paint made from animal
fat and fine clay to protect themselves from
the bright sun.
With the advent of these early tool users,
the planet will never be the same.
Early Yaetuan tools reflect their unique anatomy,
with their stone spearheads designed to augment
the preexisting biting power of their ‘beaks.’
The Andago people also craft spear-throwers
to aid their short arms in launching projectiles,
and containers to transport materials.
The Andago persist for over four-hundred thousand
years, even learning to domesticate some wild
species in a limited capacity.
Local platyderms serve as occasional hunting
companions.
Yet the Andago and their helpers would soon
vanish...
But other Yaetuan groups soon arise.
In the anticipative rays of a rising sun,
The Hulele people proudly overlook the fertile
valley they call home.
Perhaps the first sedentary farmers, these
early Yaetuan agriculturalists are likely
responsible for the disappearance of the Andago
— who couldn’t compete with this new way
of life.
Yet as will often be the case in Yaetuan history,
the conclusion of one chapter is just the
start of another.
The Hulele domesticate numerous species for
food and medicine, which they honor in small
sandstone effigies.
Most of the cultures of this period are lost
to the ages, with only stone artifacts surviving
the long march of time.
Over the next several hundred thousand years,
various groups fan out across the continent.
Prehistoric societies come and go like the
seasons, struggling to find a foothold.
But in time, complex civilization is born.
On the banks of the Sesytus River some thirty
thousand years ago, colossal stone structures
tower over a sprawling bronze-age city.
This is the Iryu civilization, an empire of
a size and strength the planet has never seen
before.
A new system of farming plants and plungi
allows the Iryu to flourish.
Through artificial irrigation and fertilization,
the empire produces enough food to sustain
its considerable population.
For centuries, life on the edge of the Sesytus
River is a paradise, with Yaetuans herding
livestock and enjoying an abundance of food.
And though eventually this empire will disappear
as the river dries up and farming becomes
unsustainable, the Iryu will live on through
their impact on future civilizations.
Long after the fall, torchlight flickers in
the windows of modest dwellings.
A thousand years have passed since the Iryu
collapsed, and from the fragments of the old
kingdom the Urgal Empire has formed — as
evidenced by the great domed palace shining
on the horizon.
The Urgal people prove to be great navigators,
creating maps more accurate than any that
came before.
In time, they even chart the planet’s eastern
landmass — the first Yaetuans to have done
so.
Uta is the name of the new kingdom the Urgal
Empire establishes in the east, composed of
city states with a unique culture and deep
connection to the ocean.
And as Urgal civilization begins to decline,
Uta feels less and less obligation to a waning
empire across the sea.
Chattering voices fill the air as a merchant
makes their way through a bustling marketplace
on the outskirts of the Utan empire.
Now officially separated from Urga, which
collapsed due to being stretched too thin,
Uta is free to forge their own destiny in
a rapidly changing world.
Utan culture is vibrant and distinct.
Lavish bathhouses adorned with extravagant
sculptures and stylized murals are a common
sight in the heart of the empire, a reflection
of a society that values art and creativity.
All aspects of Yaetuan societies are carefully
conceptualized, with Cline considering how
different environments might produce different
civilizations.
“How would geography play into their cultures?
How would that affect their writing?
How would that affect their worldview?
How would that affect their art?
How do they engage in war?”
One Yaetuan living in the Utan culture is
an artisan named Keni.
Working in a coastal studio some seventeen
thousand years ago, a fragment of her diary
offers a brief personal look into Utan daily
life.
Keni crafts high-end pottery from white clay,
adoring the sides with depictions of oceanic
life — in particular, the Vexisqalians.
The closest analogue to fish on the Yaetuan
homeworld, the numerous species of Vexisqalians
are indispensable to the coastal Uta, who
rely on the abundant shoals to inspire their
art and feed their prosperous empire.
But while Uta thrives, on the other side of
the water, the Urgal empire is collapsing
further due to mismanagement and a fast-spreading
plague.
Wall paintings from this era warn locals of
the lethal illness, personifying the infection
as a god of death and dread.
Almost simultaneously with this wave of disease,
a far greater cataclysm befalls the planet.
The Tutunea Supervolcano explodes, and the
immediate inferno and long volcanic winter
that follows all but extinguishes Urga and
innumerable other cultures.
Even Uta across the sea is reduced to a shadow
of its former self.
A grim silence descends over the world in
the ages that follow.
Trade between the western and eastern hemispheres
halts almost completely, with the two regions
losing contact with each other for over a
thousand years.
Yet this darkness cannot last forever.
The Yaetuans of the east and west continue
to progress independently in a post-eruption
world.
In time, the disparate halves of the Yatuean
people rediscover each other in a new era
of exploration, the exchange of knowledge
leading to technological innovations.
Industrialization at last comes to Yaetu,
and with it, a new world of possibilities
and dangers open up.
For while some emerging inventions are cause
for celebration — others are cause for alarm.
New forms of gunpowder-fueled weaponry and
kinetic bombs make warfare more destructive
than ever before.
Short yet vicious skirmishes called Flash
Wars break out between leading powers, conflicts
that exist in between longer periods of cold
standoffs.
Yet following the Flash War period, a postwar
boom allows industrialization to spread quickly.
As society changes, a cultural emphasis on
grooming develops, with advertisements encouraging
Yaetuans to scrub their beaks using Beakpaste.
More complex feats of engineering become possible,
with vast bridges creating new points of connection
between landmasses.
Across the planet, codependence between nations
grows increasingly common.
Living in this time of ceasefire and innovation
is Arctur, an older Yaetuan engineer whose
personal records give us another glimpse of
daily life.
Arctur lives in the countryside of a large
industrial nation.
Working as a vehicle schematics contractor,
he spends much of his time at his station
coming up with new methods of transportation
— including a new type of flying machine
that can travel long distances.
But this era of peace and progress can’t
endure eternally.
For another technology is right around the
corner — one so fundamental its discovery
is only a matter of time.
A Yaetuan scientist finds a way to split the
atom, and a nuclear arms race begins.
Once the world is armed, only one mistake
is needed.
A small political leader detonates their nuclear
weapon in an act of desperation, beginning
a chain reaction of retaliation that ends
in global nuclear war.
The outcome is apocalyptic…
“Life is a very fragile thing, and when
thousands and tens of thousands of years go
by it’s like that’s basically almost a
guarantee that something cataclysmic will
happen and life will be on the fringe.”
Decades after the last bomb falls, a scavenger
picks through the skeletal remains of a city
for supplies.
Tens of millions of Yaetuans died in the initial
blasts and subsequent fallout, with scars
running deep in their cultural memory long
after the dust settled.
But as long as pockets of survivors continue
to endure, the world is not truly lost.
For a long period, nations kept to themselves,
doing their best to rebuild with what they
have.
Yet eventually, new alliances form.
Humbled by past experiences and under enormous
public pressure, dozens of leaders form a
multinational coalition known as the World
Alliance.
And after a long period of healing, a Yaetuan
explorer takes their first step on the planet’s
closest moon.
Though one small step for a Yaetuan, the moment
represents a giant leap forward for the species
as a whole after so many decades of hardship
and recovery.
The stars are now reachable, and the uncharted
void of space echoes with the promise of discovery.
Centuries later, the Yaetuans make the interplanetary
leap, bravely launching a ship containing
sixty-two passengers towards Yedid — the
planet closest to the Yaetuan home world.
The astronauts onboard the vessel are not
just explorers, but permanent settlers.
In the early days of the settlement, life
on Yedid is harsh and exacting, but with each
subsequent generation, the colony becomes
more sustainable and more livable.
Soon, a new sense of planetary identity forms,
distinct from that of Yateu.
Back home, Yaetuan civilization is much changed,
with the vast majority of people living in
bright, sprawling metropolises.
Yet this new age is not without its problems.
Climatological shifts brought on by global
pollution causes many regions of the world
to steadily destabilize.
Despite advances in technology and medicine,
in the years to come, food shortages reach
a point of crisis in the largest megacities,
and torrential acid rain poses an almost ever-present
threat.
In the face of never-ending environmental
hazards, most Yaetuans have no choice but
to spend the majority of their life indoors.
In the large cities where conditions are cramped,
standards of living go into freefall.
In face of such unpleasant lives, hundreds
of millions of volunteers sign up to work
in the Teryn Asteroid Belt in a program designed
to create new supply lines to aid the resource-depleted
homeworld.
The Asteroid Force proves to be a success,
kindling hope for the Yaetuans’ future.
And in orbit high above Yaetu, another project
is underway.
The first of the Titanic Engine ships is under
construction — several mile long vessels
that will go further than any before.
Although completion is centuries off, the
project gives the Yaetuans a dream to strive
towards.
Back on the ground, all hands are on deck
to try and mitigate and reverse the environmental
destruction of the Yaetuan home planet.
In the era to come, scientists build towering
structures known as Sequestration Towers to
remove pollutants from the atmosphere.
In the asteroid belt, permanent farming satellites
improve life for both Yaetuans living in belt
colonies, and the millions of starving citizens
on the home world.
Trade between Yaetu and extraplanetary colonies
has never been stronger.
But life for the average Yaetuan living in
an urban area can still be difficult, which
the personal log of a young city-dweller named
Ilso helps illuminate.
Growing up in a polluted region, Ilso is drafted
to take part in an exploratory program that
will take her far from home.
For the Titanic Engine ships are at last nearing
completion.
These gargantuan vessels will be sent to distant
systems, in an attempt to continue the Yaetuan
species in case the home world restoration
project fails.
They’ll carry with them the precious cargo
of millions of Yaetuans in suspended animation,
who will be the first settlers of these new
worlds.
Ilso is one such settler.
Like all Yaetuan Saga characters, she’s
just an ordinary citizen in a wide universe
— a trend that was quite intentional: “One
thing that I really wanted to emphasize and
kind of subvert was the idea of character,
and who are they.
They’re not heroes, they’re not these
kinds of mythical, herculean, brave soldiers
who are one of a kind, like they’re laypeople,
they’re average.”
The Titans Engines rocket out into the void,
moving at faster than light speeds thanks
to new engines that warp spacetime.
In just a few short years, these ships will
transport their passengers further than any
Yaetuan has gone before.
One Titan Engine heads to Agda, an Earth-sized
planet located eight lightyears away from
Yaetu.
All preliminary studies suggest the world
would be ideal for establishing a settlement
on…
It isn’t until long after a permanent settlement
is established that disaster strikes.
In a perfect storm of tragic circumstances,
a solar flare from the nearby star destroys
the colony’s power supply.
A panicked engineer hurries to send a distress
signal, but this cry will go unanswered…
Due to the vast distances between systems,
several millennia pass before any ship travels
to Agda to check in on the settlement.
Having grown used to long periods of silence
from settlements beyond the home system, the
response team has no idea what awaits them
as they break atmosphere.
Yet the surface seems barren and deserted,
the power seemingly completely shut down.
This is not a planet of the living…
To the horror of the resonance team, all members
of the Agda settlement have long since perished,
unable to survive on an un-terraformed planet
without power.
It is a tragedy that the Yaetuans will never
forget...
Returning to Yaetu, the planet has now recovered
almost completely from climatological disaster.
Thanks to Sequestration Towers built within
cities and more and more citizens living in
sustainable arcologies, the Yaetuans can breathe
the air freely once again.
In the wake of Agda’s catastrophe, the settling
of new worlds soon ceases once and for all,
with the Yaetuans collectively deciding to
instead focus on bettering the regions of
space they’ve already claimed.
A new era of prosperity and enlightenment
begins, with Yaetuans reaching new heights
both technologically and academically.
At last, we’ve reached the present era in
the great journey of Yaetuan history.
Yet the tale is not yet complete — for in
the modern era, numerous fascinating cultures
have emerged scattered across multiple planets,
each with their own stories.
Planet Dyeti is an exoplanet located twelve
lightyears from Yateu.
A terraformed jewel in the crown of Yaetuan
settlements, the world is famed for its stunning
canyons and waterfalls.
Dyeti is also known for its unique culinary
traditions, born of the limitations in what
early settlers could carry with them on their
ships.
Today, it is a bustling, vibrant world, steeped
in culture and the smells of local cuisine.
On the other side of the sector, Planet Kekati
is a larger and more densely populated world.
A technologically-oriented planet, one might
expect to find it lacking in tradition.
Yet on the contrary, Kekati is home to numerous
traditional rituals, including a form of dance
the tells the tale of the world’s struggles
and triumphs.
Planet Aad is a more recent settlement that
has yet to be terraformed, yet the planet
has a megalithic structure that makes it one
of a kind.
A colossal Space Elevator, so vast it can
be seen from distant orbit, transports materials
from the stars down to the surface and vice
versa.
It is the lifeblood of planet Aad.
As a result, the citizens of Aad are fiercely
protective of the structure.
Armored guards patrol the base of the elevator
constantly, their lives dedicated to keeping
the settlement that has emerged around the
central cable safe and orderly.
Even Planet Agda — once the site of the
great solar flare disaster — has been transformed
into a thriving settlement.
A distinct form of religion has emerged on
the surface, which venerates the original
settlers who died in the initial flare long
ago.
Followers of the discipline are associated
with the symbol of a golden sun with seven
solar rays.
It is just one example of how complex and
distinct Yaetuan culture has become spread
out through the stars.
Returning to Yaetu a final time, the citizens
of the home world strive to remember those
who have come before, with new efforts in
archeology unearthing more stories from Yaetu’s
past.
Yaetuan history is an uneven road, but in
learning from the mistakes of their ancestors,
Yaetuans may forge a better future...
Across sci-fi, The Yaetuan Sagas stands out
due to the sheer complexity of the book’s
lore, which combines speculative history and
science in innovative ways: “I wanted The
Yaetuan Sagas to be an example of how speculative
biology can interplay with speculative culture,
and how it can be cool.”
The Yaetuans are a triumph of alien worldbuilding,
with so much detail across the many pages
that there’s still a lot of content that
didn’t make it into this video.
It’s a rare delight to see a speculative
evolution project in book format, something
the author hopes will become more popular:
“I encourage the Spec Evo community to branch
out into the print medium, because it’s
something that’s very uncommon in the subgenre.”
If you find The Yaetuan Sagas as interesting
as I do, you can purchase the book using the
links below to get the full story, and follow
Christian Cline on social media.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.